I love near death experiences yeah oh D
I go to sleep I'll go to sleep listening
to like stories about them because
they're
so uh in a weird way um uplifting oh
because the whenever people have
near-death experience it's always like
they they're you know their
Consciousness comes out pops out of
their body and then they're in this new
realm this like they describe it as like
Heavenly where it's just peace and love
and it's like uh a lot of people
describe it as like that's true home
like Earth is sort of like a a place
where you come to experience things it's
like you experience life and it's like
you learn things your soul learned
things and then learns things and then
you return back home to this existence
of just pure Consciousness and light
yeah um so it kind of makes me Place
less importance on like the egoistic
yeah things in life where you're like I
need like you know especially in like
comedy or whatever or the entertainment
you know you're just like I need more VI
I need more I need more like career
stuff you know and and you're just sort
of like oh no it's just this is just an
experience I'm just I I I should instead
of
like placing so much importance on
things that I want in the future I
should just enjoy the ride yeah and just
like try to be present in every day
because that ultimately like you you
sometimes you get those things that you
have been like working towards and
you're like oh this didn't give me the
feeling I was hoping it
would uh it's more like we going back
with open mics it's more the experience
of like the yeah enjoying all those
things of like progressing in comedy or
whatever it is and like to your point
about enjoying the ride that's kind of
where I've been trying to put my mindset
more where I'm like now let me do things
that I will en I will enjoy making now
and then I'll look back and go I'm
really glad I made that and you know I'm
really glad I explored that cuz I think
you know I I've definitely benefited
from like the machine as it were and
like I've definitely played that game
and it's like it works but um I'm not
always super proud of that stuff so I
think I think you have to as well get
like a foothold it's just every artist
that I love they all talk about it
they're all conscious of it no one some
people part of their brand will say that
they don't play into it but that's to me
I'm a little cynical that's to me that's
a more sophisticated way of playing into
it yes yeah cuz then like uh smart
consumers will be like oh wow that's
outside of it yeah but that's just a
kind of way to approach it I think yeah
sorry to yeah
philosophical no fuing I love all that
stuff it's true too like I I sometimes
think I was like more of a connoisseur
as a consumer than I was than I am
sometimes as a Creator where I'm like
when I when I like stuff when I was
first getting into content art whatever
you want to call it I like stuff that
didn't have big viewership that was part
of its appeal
through the and it about that I was
aware of it and then for whatever reason
at some point when I got into the thing
I kind of Switched and was like well is
that really the kind of place I want to
be at in my own life I think I'd
actually rather be ubiquitous and over
saturated
and just like killing it making
everyone's like yeah his stuff's not
that great but I
I'm so rich I don't hear any of it but
but then I I think if you try to pursue
that it actually it it doesn't work I
think it eats you alive yeah I think
it's a uh I don't know and I I think
this is super relevant I guess for
anyone listening to this because I do
think with younger people there is like
a a huge emphasis on
like oh go be famous you know go go go
create that's what all these people are
telling go make something it's like you
can do that but if you're doing it to
just make something go crazy but if
you're doing it cuz like your kind of
end goal or the one of ones like I
always I always use Drake as an example
yeah he's a beast like I think it's um I
know it's it's great to have aspirations
but I don't know I guess me I'm like
always realistic like it is crazy how
many people make music every day and
then they look at Drake and they
genuinely believe like I could get there
one day it's like M unlikely yeah he is
one of when you look in history take the
last 30 years and you take all the top
artists let's say it's I don't know
2,000 of them for all the millions of
people that have lived it's not probable
so yeah and I just put that out there to
say you know do the thing that is you
actually will enjoy doing cuz I don't
know life's limited and all that yeah
the thing the best feeling I think when
you're making something is we've had
this a bunch of times where it's like
you you like edit it it's like we're
making a video you edit it and you're
you're the the process
was so fun that you're like you're like
you're like I don't even care how well
this performs like I love it's hard to
once you put it out to maintain that but
that feeling of like I just love what we
did yeah and this was awesome yeah you
know inevitably when you put it out
you're all the other side comes out we
like well why aren't people watching it
but YouTube's like nine out of 10 this
sucks if you tried incorporating slime
in this
video yeah but uh but that feeling is
like the be it's like the it's like the
most fulfilling feeling I think uh if
you're into if you're creating yeah um
so but anyway I have kind of a random uh
tangent off this but I think it's
somewhat related yeah my three like
three of my top movies of the year were
Blackberry air and Barbie they're all
about products right oh interesting yeah
is that just like the capitalism pill
you swallowed it dude I mean it seems
very on its face like what it is but
like is that going to be the future of
film is just us talking about how we
relate to the things we buy yeah I mean
if it isn't already yeah I went on a big
tangent about this on one episode but
yeah I can't modern media really [__]
me up because it's all shot like
commercials cuz it's all shot for
coverage it's not like they're there's
not much of a point of view there no and
they're not crafted scenes it's all shot
in a way where it's like oh if this is
too violent for China we can erase this
scene or right if oh if this person is
it's shot for options yeah yeah yeah and
I think so yeah I think that's like a
[__] great point to question if film
is even about film anymore in ways yeah
dude I just watched portrait of a woman
on fire a lady on fire like and I know
that's like the best movie from like
France that year so I shouldn't assume
that's all French film yeah but like the
way it was shot it was like it would go
from like a tracking shot to like no
Cuts in a conversation of like a two
shot and I was like there was so much
intention in it yeah I was like oh only
one person could have made it this way
it's like the lady who shot this thing
and then is this it right here this
movie rips I haven't seen it I'll watch
it oh dud you'll love it man it's so
good dude it got me tored
up yeah I'm kind of downplaying how
Juiced it is on the uh horny front oh is
it yeah I mean a lot of it's like quiet
but you're it's like two really
beautiful gals kind of circling each
other
okay
this is what you this is what you
graduate from like as a as a young man
yeah watch two girls kiss on on
whatever America is pretty low brow dude
if you're really trying to crank to
something profound you got to go French
you got go to FR a young guy like I'm an
artist now portrait of a lady on fire I
want to create that but I but I see what
you mean though about the way stuff is
shot it's like it's pretty rare to have
something maybe it always has been too
that's like shot with like one person's
brain in mind yeah yeah I mean and you
know I think the a24 stuff does a good
job of that and there are big films that
definitely do that it's not all of them
but I'm definitely focusing more in on
like the big Blockbuster stuff The
Avengers and like all the comic book
stuff but which was dope when it first
came out and it it just ran its course
yeah I do think the funny thing in like
action series or action films is the
abrupt cut to someone's reaction it's
like that was very clearly like a market
thing like oh we have to jump cut this
moment here for this reason yeah yeah
like Avengers endgame was so designed in
the third act to just give the audience
huge hits of satisfaction where it was
like it was basically like guess who's
going to show up right now and you're
like I needed that yeah and I remember I
remember being conscious of it when I
was watching it where I was like God
they're manipulating the [__] out of me
but I didn't care I was like it's such a
perfect product you're like give it to
me yeah it was just like drugs into my
veins yeah I was laughing with uh our
buddy meet Canyon um about how like
realizing that uh Tony Stark is a
character like he's kind of just like a
hot redditor like he's the hot version
of a redditor yeah yeah like he's just
very like you know just kind of like
that snarky nerd like um Jarvis can I
get the like it's just I think like
those guys in their mind want to be Tony
Stark dude it is crazy where he's like
this billionaire who's like no I'm
actually more on top of it and and
should be in charge more than like the
government and now like it's
happening and it's like chicken or the
egg thing when I'm like did he create
Elon Musk or did Elon Musk create Tony
Stark bro I cannot okay I can't see Elon
Musk as having as much swag As the
character of Tony Stark yeah that's the
only part I can't see he definitely
doesn't talk as fast no no he's not as
smooth getting out of a
R8